[Music]
it was the most intensive union we've
ever had no matter what you'll never
like me I don't understand it I watch
you manipulate people time and time
again what can you tease for us about
the reunion it sounds like obviously
some drama went down I think it'll be a
three-part reunion that's how much drama
went down like it was it was really
really intense and it wasn't it wasn't
like most reunions where it's like
everybody ganged up on one person there
were so many different moving parts and
different people that were disagreeing
about things that it felt fair ish but
it was more drama than normal what was
the biggest part of contention that was
brought up that you guys fought over la
la la la was there that was a huge thing
you're a mean girl it was the most
intense reunion we've ever had but the
easiest on me I've had my fair share of
being the one being beaten up on so like
this one was the most fun for me I know
you said it was kind of equal parts
distributed but who would you say if you
had to pick one person got the most
emotional or had the toughest time
getting through that reunion Sanibel
cries a lot and gets worked up over
everything yeah so I think I feel like
it would be santaville two words that
you'd of this reunion effed up I was
afraid of you guys being mean to me that
I'm close
ridiculous you're very close with
Brittany hmm I love her I love her yeah
halfway very awake when we cut for lunch
she was really upset she's like I can't
do this like you like I can't watch my
friends fight oh my oh girl this is just
your first year just wait wait wait four
more years from now and you're gonna be
like the ringleader guys the [ __ ] is
back
how much longer do you see Vanderpump
rules going I could totally see us being
like like 58 years old and just still in
some way doing this show it's really
tough it's really hard to do a reality
show especially with your loved ones
soul sucking but it's so much fun in
what ways do you feel like your soul has
been sucked from doing the show I mean
you're exposing your whole life it makes
dating really hard anyone that I would
go on a date with I'd have to have that
conversation would you be willing to be
on TV that's freaking weird and it's a
weird thing to ask somebody to open
themselves up for criticism because once
you're on you're on
[Music]